we're here with the official scarecrow
character breakdown for injustice - now
this was taken directly from another
round livestream so if you see something
weird remember that it's a work in
progress and don't forget to Like and
subscribe to keep up with all of our
injustice - coverage
we'll start off uh shouldn't start with
his contacts right his Cabo attacks have
a lot of range with a sickle his back
three has a ton of range is for three is
an overhead that reaches almost all the
way across the screen so would you say
this the log is reaching for there this
is the longest reaching for three in the
history of injustice
okay very good now the trade-off is
they're not very fast and they had a lot
of recovery right so if you're a care if
you're a player that likes kind of a
slower paced but you want to keep the
opponent away he'll be a great character
he also has a Ford medium attack light
attack heart attack which is a very good
long-range move it's a mid attack and it
advances use and it invent right it
advances him he goes forward he has a
low attack with good reach for a low
attack that ends in an overhead can you
show the trap real quick out that we
really should have seen it well he's a
power character Oh hold on oh cool
you know he could have just given me
control he's dead he's trapped oh oh
that's my second favorite and iPhone
game I think it's actually yeah my
second favorite account cool the
crocodile sir yeah yeah so he also has
like a good knock down stream
[Music]
and he has strings that have overheads
and lows in the middle he's not really a
character that opens you up with
overheads and lows they're more part of
his combo attacks so if you if you land
like the first hit your right good then
the opponent has to go lower overhead
it's not the initial hit right right
so you gotta really learn his his combos
doing some fighting it and then he has a
Ford one is this long range headbutt
which I love ooh ooh that nice and you
can see his sweep has a ton of rain it's
probably the longest range sweep attack
G his uppercut has a ton of range so
it's a great anti-air his jump attacks
have great range he's he's caught on one
of the masters of ranged combat he's not
controlling space yes he's in a weird
way a melees donor right that's a good
way to describe yeah so we can go into
all he also has a really cool throw I
[Music]
love how he just drags you down all
right so um his special attacks will
start off with death sickle our deaths
pin which is a multi hitting attack and
you can actually advance them forward or
he can retreat one Oh intimidate the
opponent and this can be meter burns
you do a composter then you go back
three or do you you do do you man this
is scary really Landon is there you go
there we go so this is like his Ming
combo starter if you hit as low you can
go into it pretty much anytime you're
going to you know you can use it as
punishment go into it it's like the main
way you're to extend your top okay then
he has his gas puke and this room you
can actually hold down to extend it so
you can do it short one be safer on
block or even full one he also has a gas
burst which is a quick somewhat safe
burst that you could use in strings like
if you think you put my block or if you
want to just knock them away to go back
to your range of attacks and you can
also do this in the air it also has a
little do a slight damage and has
another use that involves his character
power we'll talk about later okay
he has this hook attack which is a great
combo winner knock him down leaves right
next leaves him right next to you where
does look good this oncogene and the
meter burn does even more damage and
looks absolutely awesome
oh really nice dose of fear gas so cool
yeah so that's definitely one of his
best combo Enders he has a teleport
since I said earlier his moves are on
the slower side and have a lot of
recovery if the opponent has long range
or projectile attacks that are very fast
he'll get beat out so if you're
struggling to get in you can actually
use this teleport to go right right just
just drops into P right
yeah you can also use it for tricks you
know you can knock them down then
they're blocking the other way and you
go in you're fighting a nightmare at
this point yeah yeah it's definitely
pretty scary to have this giant creature
show up right behind when you're trying
to use your batteries
um he also has a command grab which is
what I said earlier where he doesn't
really fit to an archetype because he's
not a grappler
he's a long-range character but then you
guys are graphic which is in my opinion
one of the cooler moves in the game and
there's his you seen the both very good
yes because it is possible through
Jonathan cranes fear gasps anything it's
possible your worst nightmares come to
life
oh my and he has some really good tick
throws it's down one it stays three
explain it took very real quick well a
tick row is when you do a normal attack
and then you special cancel into the
grab and if the opponent keeps blocking
they'll get from so the opponent has to
make a read and jump out or do a meter
burn back three or attack them or back -
away it basically means you do a normal
attack and you combo into it and you
can't just keep blocking so then once
the opponent starts to try to jump out
so I said this is a good sick road then
you can start doing the actual string
and if they jump out they're gonna get
hit that's a correct one right here
that's definitely one of the cool really
cool so any other special moves we'll
talk about um should we break down that
gimmick that character power come on oh
he also has this energy wave and this
will actually absorb projectiles so
again if he's struggling because his
moves are on the slower side and he's
getting zoned out by batarangs he could
use this and the Weiner burn one will do
a double one and it'll knock them far
away
and you can actually combo off this one
Eric would like to throw batter gonna do
better please see how fast he did that
yeah I'm a very fast there you go each
projectile who sued is over fashion
that's what I like about Jesse
so he has great tools to keep you away
where he wants to be he has pretty good
tools when he gets up close and he has
good tools if you're trying to keep him
away so a full screen he's at his
absolute best he's a total nightmare
you go to loom gotcha okay so character
power his character power is his fear
meter you can see from the bottom so how
it works is you activated and he gets
even scarier and now he starts doing dot
dam between these close to the opponents
so no image being damaged over time
they'll start taking damage just by
standing next down and you can see that
it's filling the fear meter now you're
not expected to get a full filling fear
meter on just one dose of this poison
you can see I almost did so the idea is
you keep fighting and then you activate
it again you get a chunk now it's full
now you can see it's blowing green and
it's draining whatever does this do
sieve this does traumatize which is a
full-screen ground-pound
boo now that is that guaranteed damage
or all the follow-ups are guaranteed
damage the actual ground pound is
blockable but it's very fast it reaches
all across the ground so the idea is
once you build this barrier which will
take you a little trouble you have this
ground pound active which they are
afraid of they are tired yes and then
then you sit on it you make them fear
them you wait for movement you look for
a little twitch traumatize and then you
get a big combo that's really good you
can also use it as cabo extender you
don't have to do it for far away you
know you could if you hit this just go
straight into it then get it
damaging combo from up close oh cool
the dot damage isn't the only way to
build a sphere meter his Scarecrow gas
also built so if you do this move this
one this one all right you'll see it's
also building it up as a ditch oh so
anytime the gas any time he hits with a
gas room it'll build it up as long as
it's active so the idea here is when you
feel like you're comfortable in a good
position to get it you activate it start
getting close to them and just by being
close to them they're going to take
damage like you go for a throw which
wastes a lot of time with it and do a
lot of the damage you can start ending
your combos in this move to get it up
then when you get it you can go back to
playing fullscreen back to controlling
space and the opponent knows you throw a
Batarang if you try to do a back three
or - in you gotta look out for that
ground pound you're a lot of trouble so
once it's full you don't actually have
to activate it right away you can not
sit on right you can sit on it while
it's training the opponent's sits there
and they know they got to try to wait it
out there was a lot of damage that was a
lot of benefit was really cool and then
his super move one of my favorites this
the beginning of the super move is just
amazing
and daddy can you put some in the mood
is their own grave no go visit your
parents Batman wow that's nice
you like did we really have to go to
area I think we all know what happened
sorry
Wow all right well you know what it's
it's jealous Tina I'm scared for easily
yeah sure
that's awesome that so that's kind of
your walkthrough basically the house
character work that is the basics of the
default loadout scarecrow I will allow
if you will really enjoy seeing
scarecrow but we do have you put these
together actually slow down slow down we
have some really awesome loadouts for
scarecrow to think Lucas yeah in my
opinion scarecrow has some of the top 5
I'd say uh gear in the game very very
cool stuff I'm glad your number and
things in your head yeah well as you
know I have a rating system and for
instance so here we go start like cut
you in for a bone a bone themed the
bones of his victims
so his victim was a horse yeah yeah so
his accessory there is it's an accessory
is it is and you can now see it has a
vote on it and you'll see another one
later that's very royal is all right so
the first ability we're going to show is
soaring murder where you notice he has
great range but he didn't really have a
standard projector this replaces his
energy way move with crows his fear for
now yeah murder a murder of crows and me
number one is using more crows and it's
knocked down they also moves a little
bit slower so you can kind of follow
them and this gives them a traditional
projectile the regular ones pretty fast
the meter burn one takes up a ton of
space and isn't it
so if you're playing a match we're
really struggling it's projectiles even
with this projectile absorption
you never projectile on your own mat
merry eater on twitch just said scare
horse confirmed who I mean it's
apparently dead what's on his other arm
is that just a giant bird mouth I think
that's a bird man
if you guys are all deck in the Dark
Knight Returns Batman actually rides a
horse so my personal head cannon right
now is scarecrow killed the horse and
made armor out of it to scare back that
is not injustice cannon no that's my
personal head can do not think that is
injustice Cuse that's a girl back I love
your head cake yeah that's my head
cannon right Wow how else do we give the
second ability we gave him actually
enhances the fear nado and it makes it
slide across the screen it will absorb a
projectile still and then it actually
becomes a projectile it's a low hitting
very fast projectile you can use so this
loadout in particular I made to be an
anti zoning loadout this is the load out
you would use against like a Superman or
Deadshot or dr. faith if you want to go
in an eternal projectiles or you could
use it against the character we just saw
Gorilla Grodd or any other grappler or
brawler like Swamp Thing that has
troubling projectiles right awesome now
that I like this one mm-hmm the next
one's my favorite yes you don't have to
switch oh yeah it's okay it's just worse
a habit don't stop him you don't stop
him don't stop playing like doctor so
cool so yeah I have to say as well that
I love scarecrows gear yes he's got some
of the coolest stuff I love the gas
masks
ever my mom talked about a problem oh
well toe it's too like there it is but
he's got some of the most unique year of
building that whole nightmare feeling of
him or fear yes but this one is is legit
scary and he's wearing a tie so this is
sort of businesses Castle look guys it's
a little class I'm casual you know he is
a psychiatrist he is a doctor right well
please stream just whatnots okay that's
good well so in theme with the plague
doctor outfit I gave him his move play
and this uh that's who we've already
seen it replaces this fear NATO again
and it gives him this V attack which
comes up for the ground and then is a
combo starter so this is a great move
for used against anyone that likes to
hit buttons on the ground it'll regulate
them you'll get a combo look at how look
at the range of that that's good that's
a good move now when we talk about to is
some some of these gear related
abilities will take up more than one
slot right it's when this is a two slot
this is such a good move to balance it
out and they'll take two instead of one
so the the kind of meta game here is the
plague is a great great move but if you
use this you can't equip another
abilities so if you really like the low
sliding for your NATO you can't equip
these at the same time so and that's why
we have multiple loadout so you can
actually make three different loadouts
that have this is the one I use against
projectiles this is the one I use
against grapplers this is the one I use
for matchups that are favorable to me
this is the one I use because this move
just looks awesome right
and that to me that's important to me
yeah I want to look let's add a lot of
new cool stuff yeah that's that's fine
right yeah no no no that's totally valid
do you want to do uh super games because
I do you want to do it again
I guess gonna close to you and it's the
that's what's cool to me is the super we
have here yep
like that's that's awesome yeah and
probably a challenge for the team so
nice job everybody
we go ladies and gentleman that that
scarecrow sparta scarecrow there's still
more not gonna show there's war not sure
that's just oh yes you look give me all
like what are you talking oh yeah
honestly this is a family stream and if
we shut everything gonna be too spooky
it would be too scary let's move on to a
pops up some a firestorm okay firestorm
coming up